CALLED THE ORDER PLEASE BE
ADVISED. THAT ADIO VIDEO
RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IT'S ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS HEARING
MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
THE ATTENDEES MUST REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES. THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE HEARING.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY CUNNINGHAM
HERE SENATE FLORA GIPSON HERE
LEE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS
RUBIO. THE APPROVED LAW HERE
WEBER. THE REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE
A QUORUM ELSE OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. THE MOVE BY MR
VANCE SECONDED BY MISTER ROSS-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM HI CUNNINGHAM AYE
BENNETT BENNETT HI FLORA GIPSON
HI GIPSON HIGHLY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS. RAMOS
RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO I'D BE
APPROVED BY. THE FOOD WHILE I
WEBER. WEBER HI MOTION PASSES
MOTIONS- THIS RULES COMMITTEE
WILL BE ADJOURNED SHORTLY- WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. MISTER LEAVE MISTER
MATHIS WHO WISH TO ADD ON TO
CONSENT WE AYE MATHIS MATHIS HI.
IT SHOULD BE EVERYONE- THIS
COMMITTEES YOUR. IN ORDER YEAH-
AND THEN. AFTER WORKING YOUR
AVAILABLE ZERO PROBABLY ON THE
OTHER. YEAH OKAY BOB DONNAN BY
HOLDING THEIR LOCAL. THE.